It's three hours ago.
Oh,
Jay McGraw or your,
uh,
your boyfriend is a,
I love him.
I had his daddy on the show and now he's calling me.
Now he's dropping science and his Daddy,
his dad's a fucking genius.
Doctor Phil.
Yup.
Yeah.
Great Guy.
Like people who don't know,
Dr Phil,
he's a fucking great guy.
You know,
it,
it's uh,
he,
he sent me a text the other day and he goes,
I've got this Id,
you're going to things crazy.
And uh,
so we,
we made it the Beverly Hills Hotel and,
uh,
and I play a lot of golf with doc and I know him well and I have for 10 years or
whatever,
who's duck duck?
Phil.
Oh,
and yeah.
Do you remember who we're talking about?
He said,
doc,
I never called him doc.
Call Him Phil.
Oh,
I thought I call him doc.
Jay's daddy can check them out and play.
That's what I say.
So he goes,
all right,
here's what we should do.
We should do a two man show.
And,
uh,
and uh,
and I know he's out of production and I know he's bored and he's also hurt.
So he's had that motorcycle wreck and you know,
get new shoulder surgery.
Right.
So he's like,
he really can't play golf.
No,
he's just bored.
And so it,
so it really,
and,
and I would do anything doctor Phil wanted to do,
you know,
cause I love spending time with him and uh,
and the ad or any thing he does is a big success anyway.
So I would do it,
but he really is,
he here was his idea.
It's a,
it's a,
it's a two man show on Broadway.
Right.
And they goes,
and then,
you know,
I'm not sure how it starts and I'm like,
okay,
it would probably start with the curtain opens and you and I are standing there
because it's a two man show on Broadway.
That's probably how it starts.
And it goes in.
Then we can do a Q and a and I'm like,
now we'd have to do something before the Q and a doc.
Right.
Because when we've done that before and it's hilarious.
Or just as close as we are,
I mean,
where we're born and our circumstances in life and,
uh,
and,
and he's completely under missionally fuck fucking beyond me as far as any kind
of success than anybody's ever had.
But it wa but we both came from nothing in the same part of the world.
And so we have this connection that people have a hard time understanding,
you know,
that can't believe you and doctor Phil or they literally,
we tell people we love each other.
And that's,
I mean,
and,
and to give you a good example of that,
he took me down when we flew in his Gulf stream to the Cayman Islands.
And I didn't even have a certificate or anything,
but I'd had one.
It was just expired.
And so we went on this dive and he watched me,
like I was four years old the whole time we were underwater and a,
if I got close to sub that I shouldn't touch.
You know,
he's like,
so,
so I know he loves me,
right?
I know he loves me and,
and uh,
and so,
but they're way really didn't have an idea,
but I just knew that I knew that he was,
that he was born anywhere to have lunch and talk about something that I'm like,
let's talk about it.
I cause I would do anything.
I mean,
I would love to figure out something to do with him.
That makes sense because we,
because we come off really fun together in,
uh,
in,
in a juxtaposition situation.
Right.
And,
uh,
our views,
even though we cover several background,
how different the views are in some ways and several,
and they are in some ways,
so it's fun stuff.
We should do your podcast together.
I mean,
love it.
Yeah,
it does dot guy.
he just did it.
He just did it like a tutor.
Yeah,
I knew that.
He told me
now he's exceptional.
Love that guy.
He's fucking easy going guy to really having to be around.
Right.
You know,
like comfortable in his own skin.
it was a reason why he's so successful.
It's not like anybody could do that.
Like looking at that Doctor Oz guy talked to Ross guy.
I just,
I'm watching him and I was like,
ah,
I don't know.
I don't know doc.
Well,
you know,
he,
he does three w unscripted hours a day all day and he does a podcast now and
that did his podcast because also during that lunch he said also,
I have a podcast and I'm going to start it up and uh,
and I'm gonna,
I'm gonna do a few people before I do.
You just get used to it and then I have you come on.
I'm like,
well for sure I'll do that.
How funny is that?
He thinks he's needs to get used to it.
Alright.
Yeah.
He does unscripted television with a camera in his face all day long.
Well,
it turns out he didn't need to get used to what?
He was great at it from the very beginning.
She was,
yeah.
That's the same exact skill.
He talks to people.
He knows,
I talk to people,
he knows how to listen.
That's the,
it does.
Yeah.
That's like what is missing in a lot of people when it comes to where I was
playing golf when the one time when I was going through a divorce and uh,
people asked me does he give unsolicited advice?
And I'm like,
he doesn't give solicited advice even if you asked.
So I'm playing golf with him and I'm like,
doc,
this,
uh,
there's divorce was killing me.
It's just killing me.
And he goes,
keep your head still when you put much what he said,
what he goes,
keep your head still when you're put your in a better mood when you put well,
but you're moving your hand all over the place.
So why don't we start,
we'll keep your head still when you Putt,
which now is a metaphor for a lot of things to me is keep your head still when
you Putt,
you know,
do what you do well.
You know,
it's what makes you feel bad or whatever you,
but in that particular case that is there,
those were really simple words and I know they were right off the cuff and I've
thought about them all the time since you keep your head still when you Putt,
that's solid advice.
Yeah.
All right,
so it's so it's a little bee bee.
Be More centered,
be in the zone.
I'm not if you were playing pool to keep your head down when you shoot.
Right.
Keep your head down when you shoot on the shot.
And that was a fall through,
but you wouldn't exactly call it advice,
but it was,
it was something I listen to and continue to think about to this fucking day.
It is advice because if you're really good at golf in that respect,
if you know how to not move your head,
like that's a discipline where you can,
you can apply that to the rest of your life right here.
You know,
you're,
if you're loose and you're not drinking and you're fucked up and you're not
using good technique,
your head's going to be all over the place.
Right.
Same thing of pool.
Stay down in your shot,
right.